One.
You do not use 10% of your brain you use at different times.
All of it to sugar does not make people hyper,
only tired.
Three Mars is not light years from earth and that is only a six month journey
for bats are not actually blind.
Five goldfish do not have a three second memory.
The memory can last for months.
Six Gum does not take whatever amount of years to digest.
Seven Columbus never landed in the mainland United States.
Eight there is no single British accent.
There are many.
Nine likewise,
England and Britain are not the same thing.
England is inside Britain.
10 fluoride has not been shown to actually lower intelligence.
11 there was no basis to believe in astrology.
12 Gmos have not been shown to cause cancer.
13 scientists understand full well how a bumblebee flies.
14 you probably don't ever swallow spiders in your sleep.
15 Frankenstein is nothing.
Even the monster.
It is a name of the monsters crater.
16 the sun is not only thousands of miles away.
It is 93 million miles away.
17 Santa Claus or even his modern image was not created by Coca Cola.
18 seasons are not caused by distance from the sun,
but rather the way the earth is tilted.
19 is very unlikely that your eyes will pop out of your skull if you keep them
open.
Mall sneezing.
20 dogs do not see in black and white.
The other color perception is more limited than humans.
21 talking on your cell phone will not give you cancer.
22 in each shoe was not a nihilist.
23 Catholics are Christians and we're in fact the original Christians.
24 Russia is not still a communist nation.
The Soviet Union fell in 1991 25 the sun and moon are not planets.
26 Buddha was not historically considered obese.
In fact,
rather skinny 27 Buddha is not a god either.
28 life expectancy does not necessarily refer to the age that most adults die.
It's an average and is brought down by things like infant mortality.
29 it is not required that you go unconscious to experience a concussion.
In fact,
in 90% of concussions the victim remains awake.
30 Napoleon was not actually short.
He was about five seven which was about average for it's day 31 there is no real
difference between west described as micro and macro evolution.
32 the broadcast of the war of the worlds at 19 and 38 did not cause mass panic.
33 frogs to notice at attempt to escape water that becomes too hot.
34 agnosticism is not being unsure about religion.
It's sitting up being certain either way is impossible.
35 dinosaurs.
We're not all as violent or large as they are portrayed in movies.
The velociraptor,
for example,
was about three feet tall and had feathers.
36 humans have many more than just five senses.
37 shaving does not cause hair to grow back.
Thicker.
38 red heads are not going extinct.
39 Wikipedia pages may have errors,
but the site is typically a reliable source.
40 alcohol does not make you warmer though it may make you feel that way.
41 the differences between the right and the left brain are very exaggerated and
not black and white.
40 to smoking marijuana has not been shown to cure cancer.
43 regarding cancer,
there was not just one kind.
There are over 144 vaccines do not cause autism.
This myth stems from very faulty science.
45 cracking your knuckles does not cause arthritis.
46 Al Gordon never said he invented the Internet.
47 lightening can and does strike the same place twice.
48 chiropractors are not actual doctors.
49 George Washington did not have wooden teeth.
50 Isaac Newton did not discover gravity by getting hit in the head with an
apple.
This was a story he told children.
51 your body is perfectly capable of detoxing itself.
52 low testosterone is a rare condition as often portrayed and many testosterone
supplements did not actually work.
53 it's more common for acting to be caused by the stress from an unhealthy diet
rather than the food itself.
54 eating unhealthy food that tastes good does not actually make people happy.
In the long run exacerbates negative feelings and lowers quality of life.
53 wealthy Romans did not actually vomit at their meals to keep eating.
56 the Bible does not claim that Jesus was born on December 25th 57 people have
known that the earth was a globe since ancient times.
58 Marie Antoinette never said let them eat cake.
59 human blood low in oxygen is not actually blue.
60 the concept of visual versus auditory learning does not have much foundation
in science.
61 IQ cannot be determined from a 20 question.
Online test 62 there is a scientific basis for the reliability of Iq tests.
63 not everyone from the Middle East is Arabic Persians,
Turks and Kurds.
For example,
our separate groups from the Arabs.
64 Africa is not a country is a continent containing 54 recognized countries.
65 bowls are not angered by the color red.
66 men do not think about sex once every seven seconds.
67 Einstein never failed math though he wasn't exactly the best student.
68 different areas of your tongue do not detected the different tastes.
69 fortune cookies were created by Japanese Americans,
not the Chinese 70 handling a bird will not make it.
Some other rejected 71 tomatoes are fruit,
not a vegetable.
72 cold or rainy weather does not directly make people sick.
73 apple computers can get viruses.
74 it's perfectly fine and recommended to wake sleepwalkers 75 humans and
dinosaurs did not coexist.
76 humans did not evolve from chimpanzees.
We rather share a common ancestor.
77 the United States constitution was not written on hemp paper.
78 the Great Wall of China cannot be seen from the moon.
Something Nine Thomas Edison did not invent the light bulb.
80 Henry Ford did not invent the assembly line.
81 much of Sigmund Freud's work has actually been shown to be false.
82 overpopulation is mostly a problem in underdeveloped countries.
Developed countries like the United States,
Germany,
and Japan have either stable or even decreasing birth rates.
83 golf does not stand for gentlemen.
Only ladies forbidden.
84 dogs do not feel guilt.
They feel sadness and anxiety and anticipation of and during punishment 85 we
are not born with all the neurons will ever have neurons can be created.
86 there is no scientific evidence that people have photographic memories,
just extraordinarily good memories.
87 the French have not always surrendered and worse.
They have a rather extensive history of military success.
88 America is not the most obese nation in the world.
It has the highest number of obese people,
but in comparison this is only 33.7% of the population which puts it in 19th
place.
89 Ireland is not still a part of the United Kingdom.
The North Ireland is 90 the British are not consuming the most in the world.
That would be Turkey followed by Ireland and then the UK 91 there are speed
limits on German roads.
It just not the autobon 92 not all Canadian speak French,
generally only French Canadians who consider themselves a separate group speak
natively.
93 Australia is home to a variety of dangerous animals,
but that's from encounters with them are relatively rare.
94 New Zealand is not a part of Australia,
but it is true that there were more sheep on New Zealand's than people like 10
times more.
95 the five second rule is nonexistent bacteria are not that polite.
96 there is no evidence to full moons correlate with higher rates of crime or
odd behavior.
97 it is not true that NASA spent millions of dollars trying to develop a pen
that would work in space 98 the chemical trip defen found in Turkey doesn't make
you sleepy.
Rather it's most likely that you get sleepy on Thanksgiving because you have
eaten so much.
99 alcohol is not legal because it is less dangerous than other drugs.
In fact,
it has been shown to be more harmful than many drugs which are illegal.
100 there isn't an association between increased milk consumption and lower bone
fractures.
I hope you've enjoyed busting these myths.
If you have one of your own that you'd like to set straight,
feel free to tell me in the comment section below to support the creation of
more videos like these,
a link to the channels.
Patriotic and be found in the description below.
Any donation would be appreciated and be put to use to improve the channel.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects,
we should have checked out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.